hey leute in meinem letzten video warum
brauchen wir wissenschaft habe ich das
hier gesagt die internationale
raumstation iss mit circa 140 milliarden
euro
vermutlich das teuerste objekt das je
von menschen geschaffen wurde
aber je nachdem wie man es nimmt stimmt
das gar nicht es kommt wie immer ein
wenig auf die definition an
also was ist das teuerste objekt das je
von der menschheit geschaffen wurde
[Musik]
die internationale raumstation befindet
sich seit 1998 im bau
das heißt dass sie älter ist als viele
der zuschauer die dieses video hier
gerade sehen
je nachdem wie man fragt kostete die uss
bisher ungefähr 140 milliarden euro
genau in dieser zahl enthalten sind aber
auch die kosten der instandhaltung der
versorgungsflüge und der vielen menschen
hier auf der erde die sich ständig um
alles kümmern die kosten für den bau der
iss von denen der instandhaltung zu
trennen ist nicht einfach manche
versorgungsflüge haben sowohl nahrung
für die astronauten als auch teile für
module in den orbit befördert aber gehen
wir mal von ungefähr 100 milliarden euro
aus die es gekostet hat die einzelteile
der ss in den orbit zu bringen und dort
von astronauten zusammen setzen zu
lassen
die kosten dafür sind auf mehrere länder
verteilt primär die usa und russland
aber auch europa japan und kanada haben
sich beteiligt
vergleichen wir das einmal mit anderen
großen objekten die die menschheit in
ihrer zeit hervorgebracht hat die
weltwunder kommen natürlich sofort in
den sinn
die cheops pyramide ist die größte und
älteste der pyramiden von gizeh
sie wurde über drei jahrzehnte lang
gebaut und würde laut diesem artikel
hier heute knapp 800 millionen euro
kosten
ein großer teil dieser kosten geht auf
das material größtenteils kalkstein
zurück die heutigen kosten für kalkstein
sind allerdings höchst wahrscheinlich
nicht die gleichen wie die damaligen
kosten
aber wie soll man so etwas auch
berechnen ein teil des kalksteins wurde
damals vielleicht für 400 einheiten
einer längst vergessenen währung
erworben
ein anderer ausgegraben und her
transportiert und wieder ein anderer
wurde vielleicht durch das verheiraten
der tochter errungen
ich bin hier nur ein bisschen rum bitte
nehmt das nicht zu ernst aber das zeigt
ein bisschen wie schwierig es ist kosten
für etwas zu berechnen das so alt ist
genauso verhält es sich mit den kosten
für die arbeiter auch wenn inzwischen
klar ist dass keine sklaven sondern
bezahlte arbeiter die pyramiden
errichtet haben
vermute ich mal dass diese keinen
mindestlohn bekommen haben
die gefundenen skelette zeigen dass
diese menschen sehr hart geschuftet
haben viele abnutzungserscheinungen
hatten und früh gestorben sind bis zu
10.000 menschen haben 30 jahre lang an
dieser pyramide gearbeitet aber gut
selbst wenn man den arbeitern das
aktuelle
eines jahresbruttogehalt von 30.000 euro
gewährt hätte würde die pyramide nicht
über zehn milliarden euro gekostet haben
ein zehntel der kosten der iss nehmen
wir vielleicht ein paar aktuelle
beispiele das empire state building
kostete beim bau zum beispiel nur
schlappe 40,9 millionen us dollar
das war allerdings 1930 und durch die
inflation sind dass im heutigen dollar
schon 645 millionen
interessant wird es aber erst wenn man
die instandhaltung des gebäudes mit
einberechnet da wir hier keine genauen
zahlen haben versuche ich mal über die
mieteinnahmen an diese zahl heran zu
kommen
laut diesem artikel hier belaufen sich
diese auf ungefähr 1,3 millionen dollar
im jahr
pro etage gehen wir davon aus dass
ungefähr 20 prozent der einnahmen für
instandhaltungen gebühren und
organisationen draufgehen
dann kommen wir über das gesamte leben
des empire state buildings und die 100
zwei etagen auf kosten von 2,2
milliarden dollar
mit dem bau zusammen also knapp drei
milliarden dollar immer noch nicht so
ganz so viel wie ein eis essen
ein beispiel aus der wissenschaft der
large hadron collider ist ein ähnliches
megaprojekt und videos es relativ
einfach zu berechnen das vom
steuerzahler bezahlt wurde
75 milliarden euro soll das projekt
insgesamt kosten also auch kein
vergleich zur iss aber es gibt etwas das
teurer ist teurer als die internationale
raumstation im weltall und das ist das
interstate highway system der usa 467
milliarden euro soll es umgerechnet und
inflationsbereinigt gekostet haben
aber da kommt natürlich schnell die
frage auf ist das wirklich ein objekt es
umfasst knapp 80.000 kilometer strecke
und ist über einen halben kontinent
verteilt von einem einzelnen objekt zu
reden fühlt sich irgendwie falsch haben
das gleiche gilt für die chinesische
mauer
sie wurde über jahrhunderte erbaut und
beschäftigte zeitweise über eine million
arbeiter sie könnte gut und gerne mehr
als die ss gekostet haben
wieviel genau nun da kommen wir wieder
auf den wert eines arbeiters vor
tausenden von jahren aber auch hier gilt
die frage ist etwas das über 20.000
kilometer lang ist wirklich ein objekt
gleichzeitig kann man aber auch über die
iss behaupten dass ihr auch nur aus
einzelnen modulen besteht die man
zusammen gesetzt hat ist die iss also
wirklich das teuerste objekt das je von
menschen gemacht wurde nun das hängt
davon ab was man als objekt betrachtet
und was nicht
einen guinness weltrekord für das
teuerste objekt hat die raumstation auf
jeden fall bekommen zumindest bei den
iren scheint also die iss ein objekt zu
sein während das interstate highway
system und die chinesische mauer keine
objekte sind
das war also das kleine sternchen zu
meiner aussage vom letzten video falls
ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt warum
brauchen wir wissenschaft da könnt ihr
das hier oben nachholen
das war auf jeden fall ein thema über
das ich schon länger ein video machen
wollte falls sie mich noch nicht auf
kathrin unterstützt schaut doch mal
vorbei da könnt ihr zum beispiel meine
videos früher vor allen anderen sehen da
gibt es viele coole perks und ich bin
sehr dankbar für ihre unterstützung und
das sorgt dafür dass ich mehr von diesen
videos hier machen kann
vielen dank fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal und bleibt neugierig
[Musik]